pick an arc Antioch once you pick your
arc I want you to form a whole bunch of
angles a whole bunch of different ones
on the circumference that are all
standing on this arc and they can be
anywhere in fact I'm just about through
a new one this one over here yeah okay
so pick an arc any arc and then please
draw a variety of angles that stand on
that arc just like I have okay while
you're doing that going to draw the next
one next to
[Applause]
[Music]
you can draw all of these if you want
anyway it's still an angle percent are
still in angles develop I'm still
standing on same arc okay right whoops
wrong color okay so as promised these
are going to go a little bit quicker I'm
just going to show you the guts of these
and in the exercise in the exercise the
formal proofs for these actually appear
so you can have a go at them at the time
so what have we just drawn over here
what I've got is I have there's a couple
of different ways to say I have angles
at the circumference have a look at all
those guys at the top they're all on the
circumference and in addition to that
they are all standing on the same arc
okay so I'm about to complete this
sentence but I want you to have a look
at those angles and I want you to
imagine how you would complete the
sentence what are those angles all look
like up there like look at their sizes
look at their sizes they all look equal
don't they right
some of the ones at the top end looks
like the international students triangle
but when you have a look at somebody's
down the bottom line I thought I
software is anything right but these
angles their magnitude and I'm just
going to mark them in now this one this
one this one this one this one they
should do look equal don't they now some
things look equal and they're just
coincidental and that's why we applied
adduct of logic in these properties to
see if we can try and prove that they're
equal or not equal whatever okay so
these are angles of the circumference
what do we just prove in relation to
angles at the
conference have a look that the angle
that corresponds to that but at the
center right should be double the angle
this numbers do you agree so here's what
I want to do and if you have another
color that would be really with useful
but if you don't it's okay I want you to
draw the angle at the center that's
standing on this arc okay so I'm going
to draw it where's a look maybe about
there okay
find the center draw the angle standing
on your chosen arc but at the center
like so you get the idea okay now let's
give this angular size let's just
describe it let's just call it for the
sake of it
two theta now what we've proven earlier
is if you have a look at this angle
right at the top this nice one up here
yesterday we proved that this angle is
what in relation to this two theta
it's half isn't it so that makes this
thing go over here sit up okay but we
just proved that even when that angle of
the circumference is in a weird awkward
spot like over here the same property
still exists this one is still half or
saying it from the other point of view
this one is still double okay so
therefore it's not just this guy that's
theta if this is half of this agle well
this is half of that angle at the center
as well this guy is Theta just like the
top one is Peter for the same reason and
so this one and so is this one and so is
this one
okay so angles that the circumference
that all stand on the same arc are equal
that's one way to set a very slightly
quicker way to say at which you'll
probably prefer to write because uses
with less words and shorter words is
angles in the same segment angles in the
same segment are equal now remember
think back to what a segment is what is
a segment and where is the segment in
this case
a segment is part of a circle that's cut
off by a what accord very good so here
is the cord in question here's the cord
you see the top part of the circle this
guy up here that's all a segment and
every single angle you draw in there
will be exactly the same size okay which
is kind of cool okay now we're going to
take all of these and prove two more
properties that really really quick and
they both have to do with a shape called
a cyclic quadrilateral wrong color okay
down here I have a couple of small
circles and I have in them a minor arc
and a major arc they correspond to the
same patch so maybe you want to label
that's a minor arc so for example if
this is PQ and these are the same spots
P John color and Q if you wanted to
describe the arc between P and Q you
default to be the short one but maybe
you want the longer one so you would
call this the major arc okay now I'm
going to draw a storm abies I'm going to
draw the egg centaur and the angle at
the circumference standing on each of
these arcs it's really easy for short
arcs we're used to seeing this that's
what the angle at the center looks like
and that's what being on the
circumference look like okay now think
with me because this is trickier what
does the angle at the center look like
for this big arc here's the center
here's the angle that stands on that arc
but which angle actually stands on this
arc and not that arc look carefully this
one's here in the middle it's not going
to be Disgaea because this is a
different arc to that one it's going to
be the one on the outside we have a name
for this fatter than R do you know what
it is it's a reflex angle right so it's
going to be this guy this guy
around here okay do you see it you see
so this guy is going to be to be dice
table walkers at the center okay now
just as tricky where's the angle at the
circumference ah
it's up in here isn't it I can put it
anywhere I like up here but it has to be
on that spot okay
in some ways you can imagine this
getting bigger and this this angle here
closing up okay so that guy are there is
beat up okay here comes the fun part
we're going to put both of these
diagrams on top of one another okay so
this guy in this guy we're going to put
on here watch carefully
here is the minor arc and it's angle
alpha to alpha the major arc is already
there I'm just not highlighting it this
angle here - beta goes around here do
you see that where's the final angle
below it's at the top right I haven't
drawn it yet so it's okay do you agree
everything is as from these two diagrams
down here okay to alpha plus to be done
that's the angles at the centre they're
the only angles at the centre
what are they equal to reason angles at
a point or at a revolution add up to 360
degrees so therefore if you divide
everything by two what do you get but
have a look at alpha and beta where
alpha and beta they're at this to cut
their boys into circumference right here
at the bad alpha so it looks like an X
and up here right so this big shape here
it's four-sided to record a
quadrilateral all of its points one two
three four they're all in the
circumference so we call it our cyclic
quadrilateral these guys here are the
opposite angles so here's the wedding
you ready
I can put it up here opposite angles
in a cyclic quadrilateral because that's
what the shape is called right what are
they what's their relationship they are
one word supplementary
okay